marina
io che te li inserirà comprende detto
che è senza portieri sto terranno adesso
ma ripeto da mykonos occupati ha cercato
sperando di trovarti da parte in qualche
ora dimmi cosa senti quando mi vedi tu
stai a casa voglio perché me lo chiedi
se andavo sul primo aereo
prendiamoci questo
e che ora come ora in note piero per
poche lontano da te
mancano
lontano
io mi senta prigione
all
la struggente
[Musica]
ci aspetta
dov'è che
io adesso meno rare note piero per
è lontano da te
[Musica]
i primi giorni
non solo
cento
io
[Musica]
che l'opera porta solo a cambiare
semicerchi sono qui con i sogni non
posso più lontano
io mi sento prigioniero
[Musica]
ora
io
[Musica]